jean-luc mois exceptionnellement le
mercredi et bertrand chamerois est venu
me rejoindre ce qu'il a dû dossier sur
vous également bertrand vannier peut pas
aller pas que sur bertrand
bon à savoir ce qui se passe oh non non
vous voulez une question oui aller
allons-y maintenant
bonjour je m'appelle delphine vous avez
l'air tous très amis à l'écran est ce
que c'est la vérité ou êtes-vous juste
hypocrite comme tous les gens de la télé
alors d'aller répondre à cette question
c'est parce que c'est une excellente
question que vous posez pas défilé très
peur de ce qui va faire aujourd'hui est
évidemment non nous ne sommes pas
hypocrite nous sommes aussi de très bons
amis dans la vie par exemple cyril
devenir trop c'est le roi s'adorent bah
oui eh ben on a rarement vu une telle
complicité
regardez les pendant la pub voilà
c'est magnifique
cette petite parade nuptiale oui mais
comme le coup ces images terribles
bertrand sont en couple oui et nous tous
les jours on est obligé de subir leur
parade nuptiale
et
oui oui mais on est comme ça c'est ça
mais c'est comme dans tous les couples
ya parfois des petites chamailleries
mesquines impressionnant c'est mignon
homes et chalets pas qu'il se passe et
tout ça entre oui oui bah oui ne se
passe pas que ça croyez encore c'est pas
fini sinon c'est la suite est plus
violente
non et non ce qui est impressionnant
c'est l'extrême professionnalisme des
deux alors je vais vous montrer un
extrait en le découpant ce que je vais
vous montrer d'abord c'est ce qui était
diffusée à l'antenne
écoutez bien les petites voix pendant le
magnéto meubler la phrase qui ne veut
rien dire mais qui permet toujours de
gagner trois secondes
la parité devrait également être
respecté entre hommes et femmes
en attendant on l'attend toujours en
attendant on attend toujours le blanc on
meuble toujours technique numéro que
d'après vous pourquoi il aura dit non et
pourquoi est ce qu'il est il si l'art
est ce vraiment l'extrait qui a diffusé
bertrand qui l'a rendu si on va virer au
rien dire mais qui permet toujours de
gagner trois secondes
la parité devrait également être
respecté entre hommes et femmes
en attendant on l'attend toujours en
attendant on attend toujours aux deux
décrire le paysage alors qu'il ne se
passe un spéte m'en a rien le micro qui
étaient installés là depuis hier
plusieurs minutes maintenant les
drapeaux qui sont toujours la dhr
lagarde c'est qu'on est comme deux
gamins on est comme deux gamins et il
faut pas le faire ça faut pas ça fait
pas chez vous cet effet voir des
trophées sur deux oui exactement l'amour
l'emporté toujours dans cette équipe
quoi c'est fini oui c'est fini mais bon
il n'y a pas que siri dans cette
émission il ya aussi gérard louvin à
gérard que tout le monde adore ce étape
avec qui l'équipe de aufait monde adore
gérard regarder
5000 pour la gueule confie julie arrête
de boire
ça dehors petits conseils pratiques pour
vie de tous les jours dire une version
et dansant derrière comme ça ça paraît
juste verdez gérard n'a rien vu et
d'ailleurs si tout le monde est géré à
c'est surtout parce qu'il est aimable
avec tout le monde
les liens vers la paix les tagueurs
c'est vraiment une famille débarque à
l'ats pascal rien faire gérard isabel
face à ces uns des autres couples de
l'émission malheureusement ils sont pas
toujours assis l'un à côté de l'autre et
ça isabelle le regrette
j'aime bien
belle famille famille à la semaine
dernière vous étiez pas gérardmer vous
avez montré la chorégraphie de gérard
sur sa nouvelle production musicale
libéraux et mais ce que vous avez pas
montré c'était la réaction de thierry
jean michel al'écoute du barça c'est bon
rien c'est de la musique c'est tout
c'est ma musique c'est de l'art sylla de
l'art ou du cochon
amitié rancunier en aval à ces finales à
celui qui meublent le plus dans l'équipe
ça ne vous étonnera pas assez jean
michel dahoui non je ne suis que
j'arrive à l'émission j'ai une bonne
nouvelle c'est que j'arrive je vis donc
il est la semaine et pas de contenu la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que c'est le
mois là il a comme vous le savez jamais
monsieur sait pas pourquoi fait officier
dessus au moins un mois qui s'est
toujours le mettre en valeur comme ici
comme le jour où il révèle morini bosc
avait mis une fausse poitrine
rappelez vous
si les gallois
sur twitter
pour moi ces grands produits je sais pas
quoi alex ne sont pas les chroniqueurs
qui disent des vacheries les uns sur les
autres et bas ce soir les invités qui
s'y met
m
google
on trouve que thierry il est un peu
triste honneur série qui chérit qui je
veux pas qui c'est c'est quand de choses
sur les chaînes ne connaît pas de tirer
les deux thierry passe pour quelqu'un de
triste elle faisait passer pour
quelqu'un prix spidah pour attendre et
comme jean michel cohen
je vais vous montrer le rire bizarre de
la semaine cette semaine le rire de clea
bague pour son cinquième le bricolage
c'est la france attendait
voilà mais bon je vais arriver au moment
gênant parce que je veux pas caricaturer
parfois des chroniqueurs disent du bien
de leurs collègues sans aucune ironie
non suis sérieux et là franchement je me
demande si c'est pas plus dérangeant
c'est surtout quand c'est gilles verdez
qui parle des normales à gré la ola
valeureux
il
c'est possible
non
moi jamais
sans pointer présente
à
ni de famille dans cette opération
regardez
et c'est au bout du rouleau
je me mêle pas mais vous avez quelqu'un
dans votre vie oui oui c'est pour ça que
j'étais intéressé j'atterris mais moi je
serai ta femme en plus en direct par
quoi je m'arrête pas que mon mais qu'ils
y sont responsabilisés c'est du off ça
va je vois déjà gilles verdez rentrer
chez soi rée fatou kiné des bataves et
ce qu'elle a dit anne roumanoff c'est
kaka drogba lorsqu'elle dit ça c'est
qu'à la raison avant votre intervention
ça passait très bien
non mais s'il sait que de l'amitié oui
c'est de l'admiration c'est la joconde
c'est la victoire c'est la vénus de milo
mais quoi c'est lui qui parle de balle
oui bah pourquoi le pauvre mais
puisqu'il est avec un petit bisou et
donc enfin parce que là vous avez la
pulga les copains
aujourd'hui sophie marceau dans la boum
gentil ça fait plaisir je vois tous ces
gens parmi les trahisons privées
vraiment gentleman je crois qu'il a
bandé quand même
et bien compris avant j'ai envie de
faire plaisir à gilles qui aiment
l'astronomie great wall et nora et ben
cette séquence est pas là c'est cadeau
qu'il a réduits à moins tourner
sinon tu joues dans le film
sujet dans le 100 m l'étoile est normal
je ne sais pas ses mots après d'ailleurs
admis pourquoi je m'appelle gens boivent
une famille dysfonctionnelle la flash la
flèche de la semaine maintenant c'est
jean michel maire alors vous le savez
dans le jeu préféré de cyril le un pour
tous
ah oui nous sommes soumis à des gages
disposés sur une table avec ce sera
demain d'ailleurs exactement et sur
cette tablette
il y avait la dernière fois du baume du
tigre ah oui alors tout de suite ce qui
ne ce qu'il faut faire et surtout ne pas
faire avec ce produit la main et l'on
met dans les mains on met donc ses
douleurs musculaires a passé les deux
ferries de couleur sa chance après ça
change quoi
alors sachons je vais pas vous donner de
conseils mais quand vous aimez votre
index 18 fois dans le pot la chose a pas
faire c'est se gratter juste après sinon
vous est ce que vous voulez voir ce que
ça donne mais attention nous avons
l'évolution des symptômes
détruire 17,5 millions suivi l'émission
soit 74% de bezabeh la lebanese bijoux
qu'un dîner après moi j'adore
m une pac et jubilation serait pas si la
tâche sera sur la pauvre isabelle
isabelle jamais fait la chérie à moi la
pièce
si la personne le gars et les agathois
l'émission qui lui sait les deuils s'en
foutent totalement et puis il en train
de perdre a dit le gars quoi prendre en
émission et dans ce sont les symptômes
dus à une exposition aux portes du tigre
à la la ça vous fait faire des têtes
bizarre maintenant regardez la
différence à quelqu'un qui n'a pas été
exposé à ce produit
isabelle morini bosc a je crois que
c'est encore pire essayez-vous c'est
quand vous appelez vous savez sur le
sont plusieurs fois sur la chaîne
appelée 8 plusieurs fois c'est le
magazine more problème assez à m'excuser
mais on est tous tard
ouais mais je pensais pas la question ah
oui vraiment une dernière question oh la
la
bonjour je m'appelle michel je compte
bientôt orpin de mon salon dans une
couleurs chaleureuses et j'ai dit entre
le orange et le marron donc je voulais
savoir en quelle couleur gérard louvin
at il repeint son front
merci mieux que moi
oh